so today wall street is welcoming a new
kid to the block and giving the world's
youngest investors access to an
exchange-traded fund that's tailored
specifically to their values it's called
gen z etf and it tracks companies deemed
most relevant to investors born between
1997 and the early 2000s alkali fintech
is the parent company and the etf just
started trading today on the nasdaq
there's a look at two of the co-founders
helping who helped launch it and also
co-founded the fun and i'm really
fortunate to have them here in studio
with me alkali co-founder julian federer
and also co-founder eton prince
trachtenberg congratulations you guys
this is this is a pretty big day for you
yeah thank you so much for having us
jennifer really excited to be here on
quick talks um
you know yeah i mean it's a big day we
just launched the generations etf which
is the first investment product uh
specifically for generation z um you
know it's comprised of the 50 companies
that we think are most relevant to our
generation and you know our mission with
launching zjen is really to to provide
to private investment for our generation
that they can relate with that's future
focused and diversified well and i want
to talk about that i mean first of all
how did you guys decide on an etf i mean
why why approach it this way um and get
gen z involved in the markets with an
etf anytime maybe you start yeah that's
a really good question by the way i
think that you know we've seen a massive
uptick in the interest in investing in
general from generation z in recent
years and um you know one problem with
that though is that the things that gen
z is becoming interested in are very
volatile assets like you know meme coins
come to the top of mind but there's also
like penny stocks and all coins that gen
z is you know likes trading and those
can be very volatile and can end up
losing a lot of money so we wanted to
kind of make a product an investment
product that you know would align with
generation z but would also be you know
more long-term focus more future focus
so it would help gen z kind of invest
for the long term instead of
prioritizing short-term gains we thought
an etf is the best way to do that well
and talk about what those that long-term
strategy looks like and how you are
basing the companies that you're
investing in um on julian yeah sure so
um you know we're really trying to focus
on like generations generation z is kind
of like rise to prominence so if you
look at like if you look at generation z
right we're the largest generation with
2.5 billion members and in less than a
decade we're gonna we're going to have
40 trillion dollars in annual income so
we think it's really pressing to provide
an investment that's very future focused
and that's yeah so that's kind of the
reason why we're doing it and then i
think um i think in terms of like how we
score companies and sort of the
methodology behind it is you know we one
of our goals was how do we determine you
know what's most relevant to generation
z so we did that based on you know how
does generation does generation find the
most using utility out of this company
um does generations these values align
with you know the company uh is it
innovative and is it disruptive so using
those four metrics we think we capture
um which companies are most relevant to
us well and can you talk about the
portfolio guys because you have a few
companies in it we mentioned companies
need to have been founded 1997 and
earlier right or later later yeah
yeah so so you know as you can imagine
as julian just said you know the the
portfolio really targets generation z
and is the 50 stocks that we believe
most alignment generation see so as you
can imagine there are some sectors and
industries there that are extremely
future focused you know for example we
have metaverse and blockchain
technologies um you know digitization
sustainable
technology and democratize education so
really industries that both align with
generation z and are very future focused
well and roblox is also a pretty big one
for your portfolio right yep what about
other big tech companies i mean don't
you think you're missing out on some of
the the big uh cap companies uh focusing
in on this i mean why why choose to
really narrow it down no we really feel
that like you know by kind of by doing
the 1997 cutoff point we really feel
that we're capturing the companies that
are most relevant to generation z and
also on top of that we feel like like
one of our big things is that our
hypothesis our trading hypothesis is
that by investing in the companies that
are most relevant to generations those
would be the companies that experience
the most future growth so we feel like
by investing in newer companies younger
companies they'll be the ones that
experience the most growth from
generation z from the rise of generation
z how do you prove it though uh you know
are these companies transparent with you
what is how is that criteria how's that
conversation going with them i know
you're early on in this but yeah so do
you mean with the companies that are in
the portfolio yeah yeah yeah so we use a
mixture of qualitative and quantitative
assessments when determining what
companies should be in the portfolio and
you know julian mentioned the scoring
methodology that we go through in
determining the companies and you know i
guess we'll have to wait and see
but i think that our investment
hypothesis will hold up and i think that
you know
you know it's it is projected that
generation z will be the most
economically influential generation of
all time in less than a decade and we
see that rise to prominence as a as a
you know an opportunity for us and how
did you guys i mean you're both seniors
in high school um starting an etf uh
julian you started investing when you
were 13 is that right yeah that's right
so um i was i was i was an actor and um
and i i was taking the money that i was
i made from acting and started investing
it and it was really to do this it was
really to to do a project like this
someday that you know really had some
meaning to it and so you know i think
what our hope is we really want to start
educating generation z they start
investing at a younger age and like i
think one of the things is you look back
at older generations right like they
didn't start investing until they were
30 40 50 years old we really want to
encourage generation z to start
investing today i mean it could honestly
it could be really remarkable if our
generation starts investing like a
decade or more you know prior to the
rest of the generations our financial
security could you know be pretty you
know extreme it could be great well what
is the conversation like uh for you guys
with your friends i mean are they
interested in this i mean clearly they
might be interested because you guys are
launching this but
is there a true interest that you see
sustaining uh for your generation in an
etf you know the short answer is yes i
mean we believe that there is a massive
interest in investing among generations
that will only continue to rise in in
coming years um and you know we think
that by both providing
a aligned portfolio and as julian just
said education to generation z that you
know also aligns with their values we
can even increase that already big um
you know interest in investing how is it
going to work on social media
so we we plan on producing lots of like
educational content but i mean really
the thing is like we want to produce
relatable educational content we think
we're in a unique position to do that as
members of generation z and you know who
have like you know started an etf so we
think you know we're really excited to
start producing that content and we
already have and how are you guys doing
that with school
i mean it's a pretty big lift right i
mean as you mentioned previous
generations didn't start investing and
really focusing on this until their 30s
i mean how how do you do it and how do
you convince your peers that this is
something that you need to prioritize
yeah so that's a great question and i
think i i need to mention that it's not
just us right we have we have a great
team behind us we have you know advisory
board members we really have a strong
support team that can help us um and you
know we we dedicate a lot of time uh to
the etf simply said um but um the second
part of your question was how can we
convince you know members of generations
to invest and i think again it's it's
going to be about you know
the the education aspect as well as you
know kind of prioritizing generations
these needs about the rest and i think
we're very well positioned to do that as
members of generation z and what have
what's been some of the hurdles though
to getting to this point because you
guys you've you said you met a year ago
right um what's been the lead up to this
and sort of what do the next few months
look like i mean you mentioned the
education aspect of it what else
yeah so that's um so i mean the hurdles
to getting i mean getting it started was
obviously you know convincing people you
know that this is something that you
know should be taken seriously and it is
real and i think that you know people
are really related to both the
investment hypothesis and also another
point that we felt people really connect
with it's like not only you know is it
pressing for generation z to have you
know portfolio as as they build wealth
but also i think for i think for you
know older generations they can also
kind of connect with this because you
know if you have an investment for your
kid or you want to put a little bit of
money you know down for your kid you
know this is a great way to to an
investment that's already there that you
know your kid can be proud that you made
because it aligns with their values but
how do you talk to your peers too about
i mean the inevitable risk and
volatility that comes with it right um
it's something that people are paying
very much attention to what is that
conversation like how do you talk to
your peers about that yeah and not have
them stress out right right i mean
they're money right i mean any
investment product will involve uh some
risk and and you know what we've seen in
you know the past 100 years is that over
time
markets you know
appreciate and while we can't guarantee
any you know performance um the general
consensus is that investing is better
than just keeping your money in a bank
account or putting it under the mattress
um and that's something that actually
not a lot of people realize you know
there's not a lot of people who are
investing because they think that you
know keeping it in the bank will help
keep it more secure which is a valid uh
thought but what we try to we're trying
to do with the ctf is to kind of
showcase that to two members of
generation z that you know investing is
the way to go especially long-term
investing can you talk to them too about
the taxes that could potentially come
from it is that part of the education
aspect yes it will be we plan on we
really want to we really want to cover
all different aspects of investing and
really make it you know easy to
understand but also very informative
and how do you know if you guys have
succeeded in doing this um i mean you
have the companies that you launched
with today um you started trading at 25
but but when will you know this is
actually sort of going the way that you
want it to to go is it through social
media is it through conversations with
your friends i mean i'm curious yeah
that's that's a that's a really good
question and i think that you know our
our goal as as as julian said is to
really get members of our generation
investing earlier so you know if we see
kind of a consensus among generation z
that you know investing earlier is
something that they are interested in we
know that we've succeeded if we see that
you know uh generation z is investing at
earlier ages than previous generations
we know we've succeeded and that's
really our main goal with the etf are
you communicating too with with gen z i
mean you said social it's a big idea are
you hearing from them yeah yeah i mean i
think i think for us like you know we
since since we did just launch we're
really trying to build out our social
presence and one of the things that
we're really eager to do is really to
try and bring generation z into the etf
because i mean like you know
we want we want to get as many voices
and views as possible all contributing
you know to what the companies you know
are in the portfolio and how do you guys
balance this with
school you may have to ask yeah i mean i
mean as i said before you know we have a
really really strong supporting behind
us um you know
i'm we're really grateful for that as
well and it's a lot of work and we put
it in and um you know this is something
that we're super passionate about we're
really dedicated to
um
yeah
and i wonder too i mean just finally how
do you think this is going to change the
future investor i mean uh it's it's
obviously the pandemic has really
changed the way people think about
holding their money but what do you guys
see for your generation um as as the
future investment where they're gonna
put their money and what it's gonna look
like
yeah so that's a really good question
you know we we really want to encourage
our generation to do is have a diversify
for portfolio so you know if you want to
have something crypto that's that's
amazing you should do that um and then
also i think i think making sure that
you know you balance that out with you
know like you know companies and
equities and just making sure you have a
future focused
uh future focused product that you can
relate with i think that's really that's
really what it comes down to it's really
making sure that the that our generation
you know can find a product that they
relate with because if you look at the
us financial markets right it's huge
it's over 110 trillion dollars and right
now there are no you know um diversified
future focused investments for our
generation and and and we hope to really
fill that gap and provide that for our
generation and short term what what's
your hope for the next few weeks are you
guys just it's holiday i know your
semester is over but what's your hope um
you know i think my personal hope is
that you know we we see a lot of buzz
with the etf people people are
interested in what we're doing they like
what we're doing um we want members of
generation z to get more interested in
investing even in the short term and um
yeah i think we it'll we just want
something that we can grow from
right guys julian want to add yeah i
mean i would just like to say if we can
if we can spread the whole movement you
know our movement that we're trying to
create of just increased gender
increasing generation sees interest
investing i think that that'll be you
know that's really what our goal is yeah
and i think the key will be having
investors on board and supporting you
guys as well and not right yeah all
right guys thanks so much for being here
especially
for you julian federer and also eton
prince at trachtenberg thank you both so
much of gen z etf guys thanks and i'm
jennifer zabasanja in new york thanks
for watching